ich hatte das vergnügen sie bei der
präsentation ihres neuen albums mir so
nah in berlin im asphalt club bewundern
zu dürfen cassandra steen es war genial
und ihre single gebt alles die läuft im
moment im radio rauf und runter und
deswegen muss ich auch zu uns kommen und
deswegen habt ihr wieder die möglichkeit
ihre fragen zu stellen eure nutzerfragen
es ist wie immer lasst euch was
einfallen lässt und in den info text
laden am besten video fragen hoch link
blenden wir jetzt hier oder hier
irgendwo im bild ein und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen ich
drücke die daumen und cassandra steen
und ich will sie nun gespannt auf eure
fragen